good morning so I'll give a little spiel
but honestly I think given the size of
the audience is giving the vibe here I
think you should go into QA I think
that's where the more interesting value
comes out of but to create a little
framework i am i emigrant I was born in
Belarus in the former Soviet Union I
came here when I was three I lived in
Queens in rego park for two years in a
studio apartment with five six seven
eight family members so I can I can
relate to that grime in that hustle I
literally don't even know my dad for the
first fourteen years of my life because
he would leave before I would wake up
and get home after I fell asleep first
as a stock boy in a liquor store making
two bucks an hour and then eventually a
manager and and then you know immigrants
and I'm sure some of you know this
immigrants have really figured out the
secret of American business which is
don't spend any money on dumb [ __ ] for
ten years save it all and then buy
something right and so that's what my
dad did it you know and he bought a
small liquor store in Springfield New
Jersey I grew up in Edison New Jersey
you know lemonade stands shoveling snow
you know baseball cards you know it's so
crazy for me that I get to live through
the era where an entrepreneur is cool
you know like this is like the fact that
I take ten selfies a day blows my
[ __ ] mind you know the fact that like
hip-hop artists that I loved eme you
know like like it's just so crazy and
it's happened right it's happened for
sports I think a lot of people forget in
the 1950s baseball players and football
players had jobs during the summer and
like hardware stores right like
everything gets it today and I think
there's nothing more Americana than the
entrepreneur than the businessperson and
so I'm just fortunate you know when I
was your age I was a loser buy a lot of
people's POV because I was a terrible
student and the narrative 25 years ago
was that entrepreneurship was not a
feasible way out that the only way out
was Yale and Harvard and Cornell
exquisite that created up
to me and so for me I'm excited about
this entrepreneurial thing but at the
same token to be very frank one of the
things that I want to try to dissect in
our QA now is I also think it's gone a
little bit too far in the other
direction I think everybody thinks
they're going to be a winning
entrepreneur you know xx everybody says
they're not entrepreneur that's like me
saying I'm a basketball player that's
cool like it's fun that I get to run at
the YMCA a couple of times but I don't
get paid right I'm not an NBA all-star
and I think what's happening right now
is people are putting the word
entrepreneur in their Instagram profile
and they think it's a wrap right they
think they're going to make it and this
and that and it's extremely hard it's
extremely lonely like there it's an
incredible it listen if you're if you
want this you need to understand that
there's a lot of stuff that people are
not talking about nobody in my tech
startup world is talking about the
suicides that are happening when kids
fail you know maple the food service
that was supposed to be so big folded
yesterday like this is happening every
day right and everybody everybody thinks
you know it's so easy and it and
recently think it's so easy as I grew up
when I was your age like you couldn't
roll up on people and say here's my idea
they give you a million dollars on a
four million dollar valuation right like
like that was insane that's not how it
was and I think the other thing that I'm
fearful of especially when I look around
there's a couple of us you know but for
the majority of you you know we've had a
good economy now for the last seven or
eight years right and for a lot of you
seven or eight years ago
you're a real youngster and so you
haven't lived through when the world
melts you know I lived through the
collapse of dot-com 2000 and then right
behind it 9/11 and then 2007 and 8
and I've navigated my businesses through
that that's hard
everybody's a peacetime general but
who's a wartime general everybody's
really great when people like you know
everybody's a hero when you can like
print a logo on a t-shirt and say I've
got a fashion brand right but what about
actually building something sustainable
that you can eat on things of that
nature and so for me I'm not trying to
discourage I'm just trying to paint a
very real picture this is a long game
like from 22 to 30
I did nothing I worked 15 hours a day
Monday through Saturday it's you know
it's funny I was talking at a talk the
other day I was like like it was a
Friday go tomorrow more of you are going
to have it set more Saturday's off in
your 20s than I did in my entire 20s
tomorrow
you know I because Saturday's the
biggest day of retail and like that's
when we sold the most wine so I just was
there every single Saturday of every
twenty to thirty to thirty years old ten
years every [ __ ] Saturday and so when
people you know put all the cliches [ __ ]
that we all talk I'm grinding I'm
hustling you know like I'm doing this I
laugh because I look at people's instant
and they're [ __ ] you know at
Coachella you know so so so I think
there's a mix right there's a mix
because entrepreneurship has also gotten
cool I said something at a talk that
really resonates with me which is like
oh [ __ ]
Club promoters have taken over
entrepreneurship right what we're
putting it on this pedestal you know and
now with the way that Instagram
dominates our world right and the
visuals of watches and private jets and
girls and guys and boats and champagne
I'm just like [ __ ] 99% of people are
going to lose and what I'm scared of is
if people actually knew what to do which
is eat [ __ ] like work real hard be real
patient
you know know what I would wish I knew
more than anything more than anything
and I'm looking around the room a
wonderful cops back there a couple of
people here like there's seven or eight
of us that know this the rest of you
don't which is if you knew that at 40
you felt the same way inside as you do
as twenty it would [ __ ] with your head
if you actually knew how on fire like I
think we're friends like I think we're
the same age it's crazy when I was 22 my
cousin was in the business he was 30
right he was eight years older me I
thought he I thought he was old as [ __ ]
like I remember like that's not super
long ago I was 22 he was 30 he was old
[ __ ] so when I sit here and I'm 41 I'm
like [ __ ] these kids become real [ __ ]
over
and I feel [ __ ] as young as you write
like and if you knew that if you knew
that you would get way more patient if
you that you would get way more patient
I promise you the number one thing that
I'm trying to leave here with is to get
a couple of you to get real [ __ ]
patient because that is the singular
advantage if you actually don't give a
[ __ ] the way I didn't of what people
think about you all through your 20s
like you just don't care like you
literally don't and you just build
something for yourself you have a much
better chance so many people here will
fail in their on tutorial you know
journalist because they're worried about
what people think that's just what it is
my man that's just what it is people are
worried about what other people think
how many followers they have how good
the business is doing what they're doing
where they're going what they're wearing
that's a [ __ ] matter and especially
doesn't matter if you pour all that
energy into building something and then
at 33 you're winning and they're
resetting and if you can if you really
knew how young you would be at 33 it
would really change everything like
that's the thing it I'm going to really
put the words together because I'm going
back to that time it's just hard right
like it's hard it's hard when you're
that young it's hard to realize you'll
feel that young I just don't know how to
say it I really don't know how to say it
and I don't but I want to say it with
conviction so that a couple of you
believe me but you have to build an
actual business that makes money like if
you're going into the tech business if
you want to build an app it's hard like
for every single snapchat and Instagram
there's eight million into the [ __ ] you
know like everybody fails and we get
seduced by the two or three people that
don't write and it's really funny I went
to uh I went to Mount Ida college right
it was 94% african-american Latino real
minorities college and every single
person wanted to be a rapper right it's
1994 everybody was going to
remember thinking like wow this is some
delusional [ __ ] right like like like how
you gonna be a rapper if you're not
writing how you gonna be a rapper if
you're not in the studio how you gonna
be or what happening and it's funny like
the white boy version of that now is
tech like everybody thinks they're going
to build snapchat and Instagram and I'm
like how you gonna do that when you're
at Coachella having to do that if you're
out every night how are you going to do
that when you're raising money and
you're you know you know it's funny
raising money has been so detrimental to
the startup community like it doesn't
take a hero to lose thirty thousand
dollars a month everybody in here can do
that you know and so a couple things I
want to get across and I want to really
go into Q&A like get and get real like
detailed because I'm here I'm not coming
back so take advantage of it you know
what I mean you know so the couple
things that I think you need to really
wrap your head around is it's for life
99% of the kids that walk into my office
or I come across they're trying to flip
their [ __ ] which means they're doing it
for the money and when you're doing it
just for the money you've got way less
chance to actually make the money so if
you build a business if you're in the
mentality if you're in the mindset of
building it for life it's slower you get
more true you build much better
foundation basically like it's built if
you're think about like building a house
everybody's worried about like
decorating the [ __ ] room and like
what lighting are you going to have or
what colors your wallpaper and meanwhile
the cement you built the house on is
[ __ ] and it's not going to matter
because the first time it's going to
rain your shits going to fall right and
so that's what everybody just jump in
everybody's so impatient you want to
listen I get it I look around this room
and I associate you know I don't look
exactly like everybody but I can't come
from that same kind of place with a lot
of people right when you have that chip
on your shoulder the hardest thing to do
is patience right and there's so many
narratives whether he came from nothing
whether your parents you know whether
your sibling is no one to Yale like
there's a million different chip and
we've all got them and the hardest thing
to do when you've got a chip on your
shoulder is to wait because you can't
wait to be like [ __ ] told you right
like everybody
and for that I love that I lived for
that but the best way to do that is to
actually pull it off and the best way to
pull it off is to put it into a 10-year
window a 20-year window and everybody's
in a ten month window
you know everybody rose up to memes like
I'm going to be a millionaire by 27 I'm
like what the [ __ ] does that mean I'm
like cool Mazel Tov
you know like like like like you know
like there's it's the wrong mentality
and the youth right now because of the
pedestal of entrepreneurship and the PR
nature you guys know this your [ __ ]
Instagram and snapchat is basically you
PR in yourself to the world like you're
getting that perfect lighting you're
waiting for that perfect you guys are
even doing [ __ ] just for the [ __ ]
selfie you're like I really don't want
to go out the [ __ ] I'll go there and
get you know like like people are
actually doing stuff now just for the
selfie itself so like we're painting
this image and underneath in the reality
everybody's going to lose everybody can
lose and so like how do you build your
brand how do you build your app that
takes a lot of work like real you've got
to love the work the thing that really I
got lucky with an X DNA right like when
I was born like I didn't read a business
book or go to a Gary Vee talk to get
motivated at six years old to think it
was fun instead of playing to stand
behind a table and sell lemonade every
single [ __ ] day
that's just DNA and so I don't think
you're easily and be like do this it's
not easy like you've got your DNA you've
got the things that come natural to you
but I will tell you why I'm successful
because I like the grind because I feed
off the journey because I loved the
process because I like the pain I like
the phone call that I had to have this
morning about a tough situation
shit's pressure you know you build a
business you're just managing people
fill out stress you know and so but I
love that and you got to decide if you
love that like if you're the person your
family that loves to have everybody's
[ __ ] problems on you and you try to
navigate it now now I'm hearing
something that makes me think okay you
might be able to build a business but if
you're not like then you may really want
to be the number three or the number six
you may want to catch that tiger by the
tail of somebody that you see can eat
[ __ ]
24/7 365 and what you're good at is
you're really [ __ ] organized you're
really [ __ ] creative you're really
great salesperson a lot of people
getting confused with being a good
salesman and women with being a good
entrepreneur they're very different
things you've got to figure yourself out
the key is self-awareness right the key
is self-awareness
I suck at most things really I just suck
[ __ ] at most things but I know what I'm
good at and I go all in and all the
people we admire that's what they do -
they're not good at everything they're
good at something and then they just go
deep right and so I would highly
recommend the other thing that I'd love
for you to leave here with besides
patience it starts being honest with
yourself I know what you want to be I
want to be six foot five the quarterback
of the Jets bang supermodels and have a
trillion dollars I get it I understand
people want to do things I get it I
understand you want an island and
drilling on AI or raise a family or or
started cooking I understand what you
want but it's much better to understand
what you are and build around that and
triple down on those skills like for
example for me I really like people and
so I'm a very HR driven CEO you emailed
and said hey I'm super pumped you're
going to be speaking in my school I'm
like come with me you know like I like
that's good that's going to build our
relationship how long have you been a
veiner I know that right so like we're
now five six months and we can go two
years without interacting it's
serendipity if she doesn't take me up on
my open-door policy but when she emails
she's like that's really cool they're
gonna be there I'm gonna come with me
not because of anything else but I want
to build a relationship with my
employees so I know that I'm good at
that so that's why we're a charge driven
that's why the chief part officer is the
most important person not to see if
though not the CEO her and me and like
like so that's just you know that's not
what a lot of people thing on the
outside specially if they watched my
videos or where I'm competitive or when
I'm on stage like this when I'm most
crass and aggressive but that is Who I
am and that's what I triple down on
right and so you need to figure that out
about your
help one thing I'll leave with this and
I really really wanted to QA number 18
Instagram made a lot more money than
number one of a billion different
companies number six at Google number 42
at Facebook number one 13 at you know
bein a McKinsey they made a lot more
money than number one of a billion other
things so please please make sure and I
know the entrepreneurial clubs here not
I'm not trying to suppress it I'm trying
to get people to get self-aware because
that's where all the upside is you know
and you could be a co-founder or a
number three and really really win you
got to put yourself in that Lane so
those are some shits on my mind thanks
for having
what's your name Abraham your voice is
amazing sometimes they also trap that
they throw money down well until they
build themselves a go hole that they
can't even tell that and are you talking
about debt I'm asking credit card debt
everything because what happens if you
left you said you guys can lose thirty
thousand dollars a day and that's
different though when you're lucky
enough to be able to raise capital
that's lower risk losing money right to
me you know you may lose your reputation
which is the worst you may lose you know
an opportunity which is terrible but
it's much more fun to lose thirty
thousand dollars a month of somebody
else's money than then take fifty eight
thousand dollars in credit card debt
because you got a dream and then
compounding interest at eighteen percent
you're [ __ ] forever so I'm just trying
to get clarity but generally when do you
tell that in one format he's trying to
chase that into grand jury when they
should stop stop because if they're
cheating after the wrong dream and they
look in for ten years all they done so
themselves in like this crazy hole so
two things again this why I'm tryna get
clarity if somebody's taking on personal
debt and they've been adding a good
personal they won't be able to get away
with ten years of that but you know to
me I'm always very fearful of somebody
taking out credit card loans to start
their business it scares the [ __ ] out of
me because it ends up bad almost all the
time if it's somebody who's good enough
at raising capital forever and losing
other people's money and and reputation
hasn't caught up with them that's a
little less scary but it also seems like
a waste of time if you're good enough to
raise capital for a decade and keep
losing people's money you're probably
good at subjet
let them keep doing that why don't you
go become a professional money raiser
and take a commission on what you raised
for other people like it just seems like
you'd be smarter about that skill listen
I hate telling people to stop because
you just never know the only time I ever
tell people to stop I'll never say it
here I'll give you guys what I just gave
you I'll only tell people stop when I
know them like if we were homies like yo
bro
babe I love you but they come with a
cape and this is not happening you know
like you know I I think it's a very
difficult conversation I also think the
market will tell them you know so like
what I think again and I brought it up
earlier lately is that it's been good
for the last eight years right you know
you're an Instagram influencer when
things are good you know detox teas are
paying you 3,000 bucks to take a photo
when things are bad nothing's there
and you go from being an influencer to
working at Chase Bank
you got it my man sugar this passion
I'm sure thank you well you should have
all patients really excited it's so true
yeah but a lot of them inmates I can't
see grow short me guess people that
always different we have where the risk
of finding our magic yes and the process
of finding that could be a very lost
contact exact yeah um what you should
just one does - I don't keeping it open
line and I got one I got an interpreter
because this been asked for me for last
10 years since crunch it came out region
but they call I don't have I don't have
like the right answer but I have one
answer that has resonated the most which
is I think a lot of people trying to
find their passion and like okay cool if
I love it then that gives me a better
chance to build a business I would say
the one thing is I would take a step
back and reframe it instead of looking
for it let it come to you is how I think
about it so what I would do is when
you're not looking for your passion and
you and your crew or like talking about
what you're going to do and how you're
going to do it what do you do right like
to me it's like what are you doing
and you're not trying to build a
business whether it's music or sports
we're shopping or fishing or coding like
what are you doing when you could be
doing anything and like that's why
esports [ __ ] with me because I'm 41
right which means I grew up with all the
kids that were like the early video
weird the early video game crew like
Nintendo [ __ ] with our heads you know
we're like oh my god
you know and we were playing and
everybody was told not to play right and
I think about all those kids that were
like the best Batman players in the
first year or two or the best players
that you know Doom and all that [ __ ] and
like they were talked into being lawyers
yet they could be making four million
dollars a year now as eSports cars and
that they would have just followed their
passion which is in you know 15 years
ago if you like video games everybody
would have laughed you out of this room
like what are you doing video games for
like that's a waste of time right right
that's a waste of time and now you've
got people making 5 10 15 100 million
dollars a year being video game players
so I would I would ask
first of all you got a lot of time sakta
patience I'm glad you brought that up
and to just audit what you're doing when
you're not thinking about business like
and you know and those are always the
hard businesses the sports business the
music business the fashion is those are
hard everybody likes them that's why
they're big businesses but you should at
least start there
you're better off failing in that and
then resetting as you know now you're 27
you went for it and in sports you know
you picked up other passions along the
way like oh I found out about food or I
like jazz now or you know it's [ __ ]
crazy how lifelong how long like there's
my man yep you got it
himmat my name is Lee um so I just had a
question on your no you're talking about
yes how often do you sit down and really
focus on a bigger type just saying you
know just your vision like what it was
just by profits or rinse it down
as you think bigger ourselves Olivia
might be so you know room so how do I
like manifest here yeah how like what's
the mindset yeah it's in my environment
and how do I like process yeah you know
why didn't do that why you dream big
like why there's the purpose of it to
some people dream big but you know yeah
it's a good question why don't you
delight with so let them hold on to the
mic for a second just to get so first of
all I hate that my dream is to buy the
New York Jets I'll tell you why because
longing for a lot of reasons you're
[ __ ] pissing me off but you know
because it's a vain one right it's not
super noble it's not like the kind of
thing that I can like it's not like I
want to like like you know when I work
on pencils of promise or you know I'm
going to Ghana and a couple weeks like
those are things I feel proud of like
what I'm a charity one and we're trying
to literally cure like clean water
around the world that's where you can
feel like a good man you're like buying
a jet seems [ __ ] one worst version of
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's going on now on
Instagram you know like but it's my
truth you know what people don't know it
because they shouldn't spend this much
time knowing my [ __ ] is I learned how to
speak English by watching the Jets like
I used to get made fun of and picked on
because I couldn't speak English but the
first time I went outside and kids were
throwing a Jets football around they
made me feel like welcomed and it's the
first time I felt like an American kid
and it's like it got deep in me you know
it's my truth and somewhere around
fourth grade as I started playing at it
wakil Shaw ran me over like a truck and
that's when I was like yeah I'm more
likely to own the Jets in place get up
and so somewhere around fourth grade I
was like yeah that's how I'm gonna do it
and then I never let go of it and then
to be very honest with you I don't think
about a lot of things other than the
process like everybody's always like
making these manifesto boards and
[ __ ] writing down what they're gonna
do I'm just like you know I've got that
one thing I'm gonna buy the Jets cool
you know what's really great about
shooting big is we fall short it's still
big you know and so that's why I get
pissed when
somebody Rosen's like I'm 32 I'm gonna
be a millionaire like cool like that
you're like go bigger if you're 22 you
got time to go bigger you can settle on
that and if you're doing that then you
become short tournament then you're
about the money when you want to buy
something for four billion dollars
you can't even worry about the money in
your 20s 30s and 40s right because it's
so big like that money bad actually
because if you get the money and spend
it on dumb [ __ ] you're not getting there
so I'm punting my lifestyle is pretty
humble in the scheme of things because I
don't want to waste the money on private
jets I need it for the New York Jets you
know they like you know so so my process
is to not think about it you know I've
said it it's been there forever and and
then I just make it about to work so I'm
you say it one time just keep on this is
in the back of your mind I do make
decisions based on it right I sold 30%
of vaynermedia to Stephen Ross the owner
of dolphins because he specifically was
an NFL owner there's only 32 of them I
wanted to get on the inside you know I
go to the Super Bowl hang out with the
other owners even if I make the money
they got those [ __ ] have to vote me
in like you know that's an inside club
you know so you got you know some
chipping away at that
I do do make some decisions on that lots
of decisions on that but to be very
honest with you there's a good time to
say it I don't really want to buy the
Jets I just want to try to buy the Jets
[Applause]
thanks for being here sure I'm the Vidro
so I work with my buddy Tommy Owen where
you make life source Kate works for not
that big an awesome part of what we did
with marketing collaborating with like
brand ambassadors of Thatcher and I
noticed that it really didn't really
focus on getting a purchase from people
that really just focus on getting their
followers onto our cauliflower yep
but I wondered how long do you think
typically decision-making it does for
like iPhone I listen if you're able to
siphon fans from other people with those
endorsement deals and get them onto your
platform that's a win it's up to you now
to actually get them to actually by
getting people to the place is super
important closings a whole different
skill so now a is your product it enough
like I always listen I'm a big-time
marketer but I always tell people like
if your product is [ __ ] there's nothing
I can do right I can just let a lot more
people know your product of [ __ ] you
know so so a first of all you got to
make sure the products right be have you
asked so like the question is if I went
to your Instagram right now have you
also just put out you know fly pictures
and cool [ __ ] or have you actually said
you know he linking our profile by our
[ __ ] like you'd be thrown that right
hook and say I am these great right and
so if you're not converting the next
thing I would do is I would literally BM
every single person that follows you and
ask them why not ask them like hey we've
done some stuff we'll just you know like
you don't to say hey we're doing a
survey because I'm like [ __ ] you but
like hey you know like quick question
like you know you know obviously got to
be smart you got to be you got to be
able to yeah you got to be one-on-one
you gotta be like hey Karen you know
thanks for following us quick question
right and then you got to remember how
Instagram works in the DM it only shows
the first couple words so you got to
test different words that get more
people out like you got to be smart
because if it's like hey Karen and she
might be out but if it's like quick
question she might look or like got
something for you she'll definitely look
like you've got to be smart apply what
people understand is there's there's the
clouds and the dirt right and when you
watch me and dailyvee I'm giving you the
class
right because I can't give you the dirt
because it's usually dirt for my clients
and I can't share it but what I just did
for you that's the dirt understanding
how everything works you have to be a
practitioner I've got to be a plumber
not just an architect and that's why I'm
different than most people that look
like me I'm in it I'm doing the work I
understand how this [ __ ] works
I understand how to get people to swipe
up in an Instagram ad and watch a
four-minute video from excuse me on a
snapchat ad and get to watch a
four-minute video most people haven't
even run a snapchat ad yet I understand
why it's smart to buy filters around
20,000 likes you should be buying
filters around skateparks and you know
like you're doing that it's awesome
makes me happy like and you should be
smart though or you should buy it from
4:00 p.m. on so you catch both waves of
after school not just at 9:00 where you
catch one like there's this is this is
detail [ __ ] understood I think John
anything
how does howdy how does one stop and a
blow what they see
oh by realizing you're no [ __ ] choice
like you know like that's that's the not
fun answer right like I wish I could
come with a little bit more honey for
you but the reality is like I think it's
better to go the other way right like I
think it's like it is what it is like
you could dwell on that struggle which
is very real or you could change your
perspective and be like okay it's the
odds of becoming a human being or 400
trillion to one you are more likely to
win the Mega Millions in your life nine
times
than to actually have a life so you
could say [ __ ] it like I got this life
it's not as good as rich white kid that
got a 400 trillion dollar trust fund but
in the same token and let me tell you
this I look at that face and I'm like
you know how you're sad I am for my kids
I'm being dead serious you may think
it's funny I don't want that life I love
this narrative I like the admiration
when you get trust fund a feed you get
disrespected like like my thought I look
at this one I look at you with way more
respect than my homies that have
everything handed to them because I'm
like you had it handed like that's not
fun either I've spent time with like I
used to think that was fun
I've spent time with them they're real
[ __ ] up like I'm serious like if you
know everybody's grass is greener on the
other side I get it and like I don't
want to be like hey it really sucks to
be a trillionaire kid it doesn't but
there's plenty of suicide and fucked-up
depression and all that I think the
right answer man is like to realize you
got what you got and it's like poker
right you might have not gotten the best
hand in your perspective but you still
have a shot you know like my favorite
story of my life is playing checkers
with the founder of uber Travis we're at
this fancy [ __ ] conference in Hawaii
and we're playing checkers right it's
like 2:00 in the morning and we're just
plain [ __ ] checkers right and I'm a
deep [ __ ] like it's over like he's got
like it's like if you've ever played
checkers I'm finished and some like [ __ ]
man I really don't want to lose this
match and so and so I decide to I think
about it for a little bit and cut like
over a couple moves and I decide to make
pretend that I made a move that I'm a
set about hoping that he reacts to it
quickly so I make this move and I go
[ __ ] and like try to make pretend that I
need to go back but like my hand was up
ready so he jumps me which set up a
triple jump for me and I won that's how
I think about your life thank you dick
thank you Dan listen listen the other
thing is perspective I've been to Harlem
plenty you know like not as much as you
obviously but when you when you go to
when you go to Ghana when you go to
other play there's a lot of people out
there man like you know the trip that I
said a lot of my friends too that come
from inner-city coast is Mississippi
like it's like like perspective is a
funny thing like I just think there's
only one person on earth that's allowed
to complain like there's you know the
seven plus billion of us and there's
literally somebody who's in last place
like on the rank right right there in a
cave right now as a human slave or
sometime beings you know this weird but
is true there's somebody who's in last
place I'm less sure to that person you
can't complain and I think if you take
that mindset it gets real good and and
that doesn't take out the equation being
a minority being a female being poor
being born to you know really difficult
parents situate like that doesn't
eliminate it I'm just trying to figure
out what the mindset is to get out of it
because if you're on the defense you're
on the defense because I see the same
thing happen with the kid who sits and
complained a friend of mine who
literally literally literally has 20
million dollars in the bank as a trust
fund kid he's losing everything out of
his mouth of defense like and it sounds
ridiculous but you sit there and it's
another human being and that's their
problem right nobody thinks everybody
disrespects me I'm a loser this is like
that's life you got
hi hottie look how are this very Levine
car I acted repented right no way JP
yeah I love it
did you go to John Adams middle school
no excellent yeah my brother over there
oh so very surreal - I've been watching
I want my memories back no said I love
it here oh gee yeah so I'm actually kind
of despues to learn from events people
kind of consumer health student likeness
to the people how their hand is you can
thank you you know that nobody else gets
anything remotely close to that that
right is how it starts that's it it's
over she was smart she won let's move on
okay
definitely not so you know my brother
just sorry I have a business and you
want to expand a lot during the summer
what kind of businesses we're doing like
an Isaac the next our dough yep and so
we're trying to like bring on more
people and we're just wondering like how
many times we spend on like getting good
people versus trying to bring people on
quickly and also they have a mic here is
the company in a place where you're
getting a lot of deal flow and clients
so are you trying to bring on engine
engineers to build it out then I would
go with good I'd be a little bit more
pay the only time I think you should
over expand and be just hiring C's and
DS and just hoping that some are good is
when the business pressure of like
people want to give you money and and
you're because of lack of people you're
saying no but when you're actually
building the product you know bad
engineer could really set you back right
and so they are both of you engineers or
one of units so that's great that you
got like I would look at
entrepreneurship has created some
funny-ass [ __ ] including two
non-technical co-founders building
technical products and outsourcing and
getting [ __ ] so that you guys are in a
good spot what I would do
to be frank you're young right like I
think you should be spending every
minute on it like I think you should be
interviewing people at 10:00 p.m. at 11
p.m. at 6 a.m. like I would
speak I would try to get 2015 ten
interviews into a day instead of three
four five that's how I would probably
attack it because you're going to need
to win on quality are you having are you
guys having a problem with deal flow of
getting good talent are you guys
spending any time in communities like
meetup or reddit or other places where
there's a scale of people talking again
I mean awesome the good thing is your
tech down right so like you know you
know you know what's so crazy and I
think you guys some of you know this
crazy that bulletin boards are still
around and like kind of real right like
so I know when a lot of my engineering
talent is looking for talent they're
stunning to me that they go into some of
these Ruby or Python bulletin boards
even you know slack channels I think is
a place where you can siphon some
Republic's lack channels is a place
where I think you could find some
engineers so some details like that you
please you're welcome
I'm doing music Jerry caption content
for Allah so thank you things that
really thank you
I'm just starting a business now myself
good with a few friends rocket design
phase and I wanted to know when it comes
to course designing and then marketing
is building the website there's only
three of us do you think is smartly to
focus on one thing at a time maybe what
it what's the business interest
important look at this you might need
ends it happens a lot so you have you
designed the product yet it basically
industries have the many effects and so
is there anything stopping you is it
money is it the right partner is there
anything stopping you from manufacturing
it well I mean now among the definitions
over okay
and so you're going to clearly sell this
on Shopify right so you should
definitely build it on Shopify because
that means you won't have to really
build the site so you'll be set there so
that's good I'm glad you came to this
talk and heard about shop ok yeah so I
mean I think you're you're in motion
right if you get the product the site's
going to be once you Google out Shopify
and learn how to do it that really
low-cost way to be into retail so that's
huge and then and then on the marketing
front I think it's hard core influencer
marketing obviously you've got a public
back to your thing you might have gotten
the wrong influencers right like maybe
they gave you yeah the long tail is
always more interesting because a lot of
people really pay like if somebody has
18,000 followers a lot of times those
18,000 are really watching and following
you start getting to that high level it
just becomes passive in one feed uh-huh
so going to find the right influencers
and just kind of scrap right you just
got to get awareness you know but shoot
for the moon like you should hit up and
you look you should slide into the DM of
like every single major skateboarder in
the world and ask them to put you on and
99.999% of them will say no but if one
says yes everything changes it's just
grind it just it's a game of numbers
like do you have the perseverance like
do you love no the way I love no I
No you know because no get followed up
by I [ __ ] told you
welcome here during the Entrepreneurship
church authorities personal brands
related how can we college seniors and
recent grads for building a personal
brand to potentially build a business in
order to get higher as a company we want
to be higher talk about [ __ ] you know
Ken yep oh you know everybody's trying
to build a personal brand it became this
thing
it's crazy you're holding crush it's
like when I wrote that people didn't
even know what the word meant right like
people laughed at the book you're
holding like Hispanics ten years ago
like the thought of like go on YouTube
people didn't know what YouTube was and
Twitter was like I was like go on
YouTube okay you know I went on CNN all
the cerebrum literally these are the
interviews you can find them on Google
like not on YouTube like I'm like go on
YouTube and Twitter and hosts is like
CNN the host of like what's YouTube like
like it seems crazy now but everybody
wants to do that like the way you build
a personal brand is people want to
follow you right so why would people
want to follow you you're pretty you're
funny you're smart you're motivating
like like you got to have something but
the thing to do is not the front
everybody's playing an act which is a
house of cards you need to speak your
truth we hook you didn't create document
don't create like like all those people
just gave you DAPs because you're
clearly a likable dude like that's going
to play out that's a winning formula
that's the [ __ ] I had to write I just
also first of all and this is something
you got to think about miles had just
decided to put my head down for 12 years
before building a personal brand because
it was a lot more slender there's a
personal brand around building an actual
business you know the reason I came up
with document don't create was it gives
a kid like you a shot so you could you
know you could either put your head down
for 15 years pop out and then start
building or right now you could just be
like I'm Kenny like I got it this is
what I got going on
right
not much yet like I'm not going to give
you business advice and I haven't built
the [ __ ] business but I could surely
tell you what [ __ ] kids buck worth
right now like you know like you could
talk about your life culture like
everybody wants to listen if you'd like
I knew this gets a little bit into
younger than this demo but you might
have some younger nieces nephews kids
I knew slime and spinners were coming
because I watch a year old so like you
know it's money I could have made by
buying [ __ ] a bunch of spinners in
China and selling them on Amazon there's
people making a hundred thousand racks
like [ __ ] real money like real money
like every week on Amazon because nine
months ago they saw kids going to [ __ ]
with spinners and they started buying a
shitload of them in China and they
ranked first on Amazon like peeps like
everybody in the world wants to know
what you guys [ __ ] with every fashion
brand every soda brand every sneaker
brand so tell them you don't have
valuable of a show and how many people
would follow you if your day was walking
around this campus and just asking
people like what's your favorite song
what's your favorite soda what's your
favorite brand that's valuable I'm
interested do you think your granny will
eventually replace for everything
sure if you define it as I definitely
don't give a [ __ ] what your resume says
I'm far more interested in when our
interview is going to feel like and if
I'm intrigued I'm definitely going to
your social to figure out who you are
like I know when jet players are not
going to be good by the way they treat
their friends and women on social media
it's crazy I like this guy's a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] sure enough suck like you
know like it's correct people it's hell
yeah
what I'm going to listen your [ __ ]
piece of paper versus where your actions
welcome
[Applause]
very that was a little flag right there
like there's a single roll too much give
us out to be so yes Rajesh - none of
this weekend it wasn't Amazon
Larry's on the kids were they so my
question is on senior let's London
earring
however Abbott has a group maybe of like
on coping like my dad in Ecuador I love
the business there but I'm gonna have
his own thing I'm a senior and I got a
few things I know and Amazon thing just
so everybody learns is you're buying
[ __ ] stores and reselling it on Amazon
and making a profit
exactly I don't even want to get into I
don't know if you guys you know this
whole thing started because I was on
Breakfast Club right yeah and Envy tried
to call me out try to [ __ ] gas me up
I said okay and you [ __ ] you watch this
and I drew and I dropped the whole thing
and it's guys I'm getting 500 emails a
month right now for people like I make
twenty three thousand dollars a year
we're broke I got $40,000 in credit card
debt
I live with eight family members and
this ship changed like I go to Marshalls
now everyday and I'm making 200 extra
bucks so like it's crazy what's going on
on Amazon and eBay like you can
literally if you got three hours make
hundreds of dollars every day by just
going to stores like TJ Maxx and
Marshalls and dollar store scanning [ __ ]
looking for how much it's on for an
Amazon buying it and selling it it's
[ __ ] it's crazy right what are you
flippin so both been doing wholesaling
and actually I pay for my daughter's a
trip to that money so that's really
amazing how much time you're spending on
it our problem spends in the beginning
part of that baby ten-hour rich is
watching YouTube videos and be ending
people but in an hour I just saw like 10
hours and it's incredible so far connect
like what do you what are we by going to
places to buy researching products oh my
god you're doing it all online
oh yeah
the defining [ __ ] yet a few long
extensions when an Amazon luminous
German Scout Shepherd purchase later on
at the Dublin predicted you just gonna
stand up here whatever we have that
whole money to still be willing to quit
and suddenly finds out our investment
well I want talk about your estimated I
did that on a plane a thousand dollars
already within the net and I one more
time break that down for me how much in
investment so I put it that does the
stories actually point those working
home and upon a book design book I sold
it to check the eighties because of
business then was in my girlfriend's
library and I bet you got book you ever
read and you take a little change the
old books from the library
no girlfriend yet here you go even
better cause it seems like hotties on
her I like it okay I think that I'm
listening
I made a few both the profit they're not
just its resource guide I'm telling you
if you need like this is just a
different thing if you actually want to
be an entrepreneur selling is always a
good idea engineers skateboard doesn't
matter whatever your background is
selling just to learn it just to taste
it is a foundational thing at the end of
the day it's what you're going to do you
can build the best product something's
going to sell it you might as well have
a little knowledge of it like everybody
should be grounded in selling right now
while you've got time and you've got
time just so you know lots of it
lots of it start going places and buying
[ __ ] like get the app the scanning apps
on on your phone like make to three
hundred dollars a week on your five to
twelve our investment of going places
listing it like it is a foundational
thing that will serve you well and you
might as well put a couple hundred bucks
in your pocket each week to and God
forbid you stumble on something like
this will happen and then and then the
spinner or the slime or something
happens or you walk into the right store
doing the right closeout you scan
something and it's selling for 35 bucks
on Amazon and it's three dollars a piece
and they got 400 of them and you've been
saving up and making some money and you
go all-in all sudden you got four
thousand dollars on that five dollar
investment this is the emails
500 emails a month that started with
dying dollars now have 4,000
dollars but that's a little less Madden
that's a little less listening to all of
logic and Russ's songs on repeat four
hundred times a day that's a little less
hanging out like it's worked so well
since I'm I don't know my dad yeah I
love this beautiful to the world because
I found myself months ago of it do you
think the good idea to do it all because
he's not anything so I don't what's he
do
so those products to like help flowers
last longer whether you come here or
coaches there's a lot more I guess
greener and difficult how much you got
he's probably 67 but he got a stay in my
home I would tell you the reason I see
how old I think you know I would wait by
the same token there's nothing like
working with your family like you know
maybe can go back and forth I don't I'll
tell you good news I don't think there's
a wrong answer here I think either way
it's gonna be right all right got it
[Applause]
so Gary how are you mommy thank you
thank you
so I had a question we got mark being a
little bit of our viewership let's go a
little too personal business Mike
laughing clear yep I would work for
myself
for the public so I got a good heart but
we will be like incur certain buzzwords
like products sales so I'm wondering if
you could speak a little bit on how to
when your product is an idea is a
concept like a balances right I'm bill
from trying to deal with a web traffic
Apollo's okay battle by community
resources they make that cut Elena's not
gonna just understand it will be now I
get it but when I say father
Congrats my girl there's nothing out
here to admit everything back but at the
same time what I'm doing magic at the
blog find us get more to regular due to
being deaf I'm creating consistent
content you haven't acted at that time
you're not an idea you're a media
company so what you need to realize is
you're a media company and how do media
companies make money they make money on
subscriptions you've got to sell your
content what's hard about selling
content is there's a lot of it out there
like a lot of people here don't want to
pay for content because sure this person
might be selling an eight-dollar thing
but they know they can find it for free
somewhere else we don't we don't love to
pay for content but if you're good
enough they will and so here are a
couple things you should do keep pumping
out tons of content it's your only shot
and then you've got to build an actual
fan base that cares about you like
personal brand they have to care they
have to care enough to pay for something
if you have enough fans that love you
well then all of a sudden HarperCollins
comes along and offers you $100,000 to
write a book that's one way to make
money if you people that love you and
care about you and you brought that
value all of a sudden people might pay
you $500 to give your first speech right
and then it builds right or if they
really love you and and they care about
you and you brought them value maybe you
start maybe you start doing a father's
retreat right and and maybe a fan of
yours own some property upstate and so
they don't charge you and so now when
you charge $200 a head and 150 people
come and you have no overhead because
the fan
you brought value to gave you the
property for free so you've got to treat
yourself like a media company and so
it's not an idea you just have to put
that energy and that content and that
fan base into buckets that you can
monetize but first my man you have to
actually build a community I love it
you know just build it right now is the
time you should work for somebody right
nine up nine two three just right get on
but it's that late nights of stuff like
rush it was a breakthrough for me
because I started talking about that
7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning right
because I want to be practical it's not
like hey quit it's going to all be
alright continue to
years to get to a place to have leverage
where people going to pay you for the
things I just broke down what are you to
do in those two years right so I'm a big
fan of getting that job that's kind of
lightweight and just paying you and it's
easy I don't care to stand behind the
register of a slow store so you can work
now with phone [ __ ] right like when I
wrote that it was desktop computers now
with a phone you could be building your
business while you're standing behind
the register at Saks with a veneer like
nobody's up there you just building your
[ __ ] ain't getting paid I love that
welcome let's go more like about morale
anything going on yes laughter yes Oh
almost every yoga fishing every CNN yes
yes negative immigrant yes yeah you know
it's funny right because I gave that
young man the same answer I you know and
I spent a lot of time with minority
female friends in the last year about
this like to me I just try to remind
them its perspective I genuinely you
know what I'm about to say is very very
uncomfortable because I'm a white dude
but I'm going to say it because I think
it's my truth I genuinely believe that
happiness is much more of a mindset than
people realize you're more than welcome
to look at those things and you're
getting pounded by them but I've been
lucky my whole life forget about being a
dude just even when I was a bad student
I just don't listen you know I think
that you never had more opportunity than
you have right now I understand the
propaganda that's being pushed but the
reality is the internet doesn't give a
[ __ ] the market doesn't give a [ __ ] you
know what's really funny like when it
comes right down to it people want to
make money people want to win people
want to be happy
I just think you're way more in control
than you think like like I don't know
what else to tell you like what like now
you know like obviously for the really
unfort listen I didn't get my green card
until I was like 19 like my family like
you know was procrastinating our
citizenship I think about it all comics
hoc we could have not really caught you
know like like unless you're sitting
with not the right paperwork which I
think has been a real conversation I
have no interest in like sitting on a
soapbox but if you're set and you're
here you have it really good I don't
care what people say there's an
unlimited amount of application first of
all old white dude like angry white dude
they can't stop you like what are they
going to do like this is like what like
the cliche angry white dude that we're
referring to isn't in a power position
to begin with sure angry white dude like
all these 28 your angry like what like
they're leaving and like 64 you're like
when you say really let me tell you
about 64 year old white dude he wants to
make money and if the brown girl can do
it for him
they're in that's just the truth
that's the part that nobody talks about
like nobody's stopping you
like Jeff sucker can be running CNN
breaking news because he wants ratings
and it might be tricking you but you're
letting it trick you so I I would change
your mindset like you've got you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want like you can
you can it's hard do I think it's harder
for you yep and I think so right like
it's the people need to be reminded like
people like you know so weird but like I
was I'm telling you like the little
bubble I lived in and again some of the
four-year-olds here know it was only
school like I was an F student I had no
chance like I think you can win I'm
positive you can win you just need to
start changing your mindset [ __ ] them in
organization
getting online along like Social Work
love it rather than autonomy business I
would do a lot of listening and I would
do a lot of documenting you know like
the media's what's palatal right so if
you're trying to make a change first
know what change you're trying to make
listen to the community
don't be idealistic of what you want you
know one of things that's been really
interesting is as I've gotten into
social efforts of exact nature is people
have their opinion of what they want for
the community not what the community
wants for themselves right people get on
their high horse how they want it to be
so first thing I would say is you know
you maybe look exactly like them but
make sure you hear them because it's a
psychological game right not a facade
game you know so first know what they
want once you understand what they want
literally with your iPhone making videos
and posting them on Facebook and in some
we live in the greatest time ever we're
in control of the media the media run
[ __ ] why do you think dictators or when
there's a coup in a country they take
over the media first the media makes you
think [ __ ] that beautiful wonderful
woman right there believe those [ __ ]
pump in that negativity because that's
what that's where humans I get it I'm
not mad at you that's the game so the
fact that we now have that at our
fingertips like film post distribute
deal which money that cost a media
company my man over there like Z like
for me to say you're a media commit is
crazy you needed people to pick you you
need to wait for years you need to get
lucky in Hollywood you need to have 800
people put you on and take all your
money out it's all you the internet
changed everything it is the biggest
change in our success we grossly
underestimate it you take it for granted
we underestimate it it's the biggest
shift in human culture ever and that's
why I'm optimistic that's where I'm
optimistic because you have so many
options that's why I'm optimistic that
you can actually make a change where you
couldn't have 30 years ago unless you
were one very special human of all time
now you can make that change create
content around the true stories that
people need to hear them welcome
[Applause]
so I fought it off pretty soon Caroline
ensemble by Christian Christian apparel
line on Shopify stopped by a few months
ago we heard about savasana journey
yep yep so there are the greater quality
behind milk cow so it's not though cow
that I'm selling short so and on songs a
focus on putting that in front line and
providing the line of purpose and I
haven't been so much on what's protected
what's the technical details besides of
being Christian you know like what
happens with the money you donating all
of it no I'm only no understand but my
question is Joe is that I'm really
really focused on Ashley on device the
reason I ask a question I made that joke
is you need to be make you need to
really make sure that you walk the fine
line when you get into cos are good for
profit you need to make sure you're not
full of [ __ ] or people smell it right
and it's okay you should make money
there's nothing wrong with that but make
sure you know like I love them people
like oh you know so Tom she's remember
that back in the day I was super
friendly with him he came from a decent
place like he actually he was the first
guy who's like [ __ ] like I really
want to make these shoes and I want to
really give a pair of shoes but then
every [ __ ] huckster entrepreneur came
through my office was like okay cool yo
listen check I'm starting an umbrella
company and when you buy one umbrella I
give one umbrella to the kids they get
rained on right like everybody just
became like he was just making up [ __ ]
and then I would look under the hood and
I'd be like why is your candy bar where
you're donating one twice the price of
every candy bar oh I see you want to
keep all the money still but you want to
front like you're doing some good so
your push it is double the price you're
not actually giving you're inflating the
price so that you can look like a good
Christian I'm not saying that's when
you're saying I'm saying you need to be
careful because that's what everybody's
thinking right so my pleasure you going
play soft but extreme focus on the
purpose the cause behind it yes and I'm
not filthy enough understood so I was
wondering what we like sleep suggestions
in like balancing that out well what do
you think salesy means to you well I
think I put it I think more of a
prospectus then you are being read
somewhere for a long time going up and I
don't know like they put the bomb you
like all you guys do that until you
became visceral to it yeah I think
that's what it is so so what about just
wanting Facebook ads against Christian
Americans with $100,000 income levels
right so I've done that then Tom I'm
trying to still exercise though messages
behind it rather than a t-shirt itself
so looking down so how are you doing
that that's one of my concerns right now
so one so you need to pump content yes
that's on the way I'm currently doing
that okay
but the sales aren't keeping enough
right off right right
so why'd you stop doing the Facebook Ads
idiom work I decide to revamp my entire
website and just sit back strategize
from my head down and now both continue
all beautiful Gavin I love it yep yeah
to be very frank I just think it sounds
like it's early yeah like I think you
just have an early talk right now right
like patience seems to be the weirdest
running through my head I'm like you
know what you clearly know what you got
to do right like put you know create
content about the purpose behind it and
run ads and try to sell the other stuff
and if you feel like you're not salesy
enough hire a partner or a head of sales
to like worry about that so you can put
on it sounds like maybe you don't want
to put your energy in that and maybe you
need somebody to focus on the sales so
that you can focus on the purpose right
thank you patient you know just keep
pulling levers
okay hashtag Christian hashtags on
Instagram click it see the top line post
click or 33 up good hey good morning
morning I want to piggyback on island
your idea no toy yes now the board is on
we work for a company understood
I've heard that hard stuff we have seen
the most empowering thing you'll all
have like you agree style now I wanted a
picture of you on what you think about a
flag hustle and whether not both to just
drop it and focus on one ah I think
you've got to know the person right so
like I do think if you look at the data
like focusing on one business always
works out better than three like you
know I was sick tell kids when they roll
in they're like all right yo I've got
this umbrella company I got a sneaker
company I got a babysitting company oh
and I sell like bananas on the side
right I'm like all right cool
I'm like when you got four businesses
you have no businesses right so but I
look at myself I've got my core
businesses but I'm so entrepreneurial
and I love the action so much I do side
things here and there I almost always
lose because I'm not focused on it and
I'm relying on somebody else
but I need that action to met me
actually do my main thing like the side
of stuff you know it's like a good meal
right like I like the sea bass but like
the English peas I need that to to make
the whole meal right and so I think that
you've got it's more reverse-engineering
the person you know but I do think that
it's much more fun to start creating
side hustles after you have something
that's stable and can afford the loss of
the side hustle instead of thinking the
right strategy as three things because
you do definitely get stretched in and
it's very guys 99% of small businesses
don't win like when are we going to
accept the math it's hard right like
we're just the vibe feels like half of
us are going to make it one person in
this room is going to make it like for
real you know because when [ __ ] hits the
fan I can't say it enough when when the
market crashes that's when you have to
have a big enough business to get
through there's a lot of people here in
24 months that might be on their way but
then the money falls out
and people aren't buying anymore then
your suppliers want their money then you
know like just we can't keep we can't
kill this guy yeah
cool awesome very thank you that I can
show thank you my personal I'll take
over the business
yeah and although yes my baby's in
European post or Italian blood adjuster
so the demographics changed due to some
of this personal issues and laws we love
discrimination because they have evils
alcohol I can get a job but mr. Columbus
yep
so between social media engagement and
lack of capital what can I do that and
bring back some revenue into the
business so you're going you're going to
be so it's a it's a deli Anna what right
like um and and lack of capital and what
else I'm part of it as well and he'll be
cool with you becoming more of the
public face because he knows that needs
to get saved I'm currently going through
some barriers with yeah because you know
I mean notice I asked a pretty unique
question like everybody would assume
sure right look sometimes things fail
for those reasons if your dad is able to
have the humility that he knows he has
no other choice but to let you become
the face because of the damage control
then you got a prayer because then you
can go on heavy offense of creating
content on an hourly basis that puts you
at the forefront and what's great about
local businesses is it won't take long
for the word of mouth to go right and
I'm going to assume like it also sounds
like has the other business for a long
time a new way so great so like a lot of
people don't want it to go like
underlining you know if it's a more
recent phenomenon people are as much sad
as they are bad right so I think if you
can get your face in front of it and
then I would start just doing I would
start doing guerrilla marketing
like stunt marketing like the only thing
you've really got as an asset is your
inventory right so I would start doing
this is a risky move this is really what
I would do I would start doing I've been
thinking about doing this for Vayner for
Wine Library I want to do something
called free food Friday like literally
literally just give away $20 gourmet
credit at Wine Library on Fridays for
like four hours just to see what the
[ __ ] would happen just feel sure you
know like like you know obviously you
can't take that big of a financial risk
but maybe a version of that because I
start giving back to the community I
would do really weird [ __ ] like I've got
a really weird one for you I think that
the first day it snows that you should
kind of stick with me here I think you
should go I think you should go and
shovel people's yards as a thank you for
being a customer like stuff that's tunki
that could like change the mood right
like when you need to change the
momentum you can't change it by doing
little things right you need to do big
things weird things things that have to
be you know owning and like we want to
give back to the community so like a lot
of community stuff I would I would
literally put a search query around that
entire town on Twitter and Instagram and
I would literally as the business reply
to every single [ __ ] comment like if
you're going into the business right
you're gonna be similar to how I rolled
in there's gonna be sitting there right
leave [ __ ] spin there so the [ __ ] man
if I had a [ __ ] mobile phone when I
was sitting there I would've been able
do even more damage right and you could
just literally search your town
Porchester like we searched it look in
every photo just [ __ ] pound pound
pound Pat you know like you see some kid
who's got like 4000 followers because in
local high school drinking a Gatorade DM
and be like y'all give you Gatorade free
for this whole month come through take a
photo with me like it can happen fast
you see where I'm going your asset
credits a problem or kids like you're
going into a fire right but you're still
a product some right like I'm sure
there's food and there's stuff in it
beautiful that's your ammo your ammo is
your hustle and the [ __ ] product
thank you welcome